I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense do you feel like this sort of
perspective on the relationship is a
result of being in an open relationship
certainly knows good Lord it's hard
enough please tell me how you dealt with
more and why like what why that that
would make it harder I would think but
go for it was you're having a great
great transition it was it was one of it
was the hardest thing I've ever done
I've never felt more suffering more pain
more ego destroying moments where I mean
there was moments where you know Whitney
would be with one of her other lovers
and I would be in so much discomfort in
all aspects of like particularly
actually I would be like I was like I
remember one time in New York I was like
crawling around on the ground she was
with a particularly aggressive lover and
that was like really hard for me you
know at that point and like I was like
crawling around on the ground and I like
I didn't know if I wanted to throw up or
like punch a wall or like cry or and I
just I just had to start proud and pray
often but I just had to actually start
praying I was like please help universe
like please I can't go any further why
don't you guys agree to this well that's
the that's the challenging part but what
the the reward is of those challenges is
you start to realize you start to
understand why that is hurting why is
this hurting me sure what is causing
this pain why is her enjoying herself
and enjoying somebody else why is that
causing me pain why is her happiness
causing me pain that does that need to
be there or is this my attachment my
competition my desire to be the special
one my desire to be validated as the
only one that she's attracted to which
makes me greater than everybody else
which boosts playing like what are the
reasons behind this and then you start
to get really curious about that when
you really understand like this
shouldn't feel this bad she's having fun
or I'm having fun and we're feeling so
terrible
we don't have to feel that terrible so
it ended up being the most valuable
learning process that I've ever had and
I really realize through this process
that I was I required the validation of
a lover to make me feel like I was
worthy of love I required them like
wanting me in a sexual way in order for
me to feel like I was worthy of even
loving myself and this unwound that
pathology through pain and introspection
and and allowed me to really understand
that which allows me to feel like I'm
whole and I don't need anything that I
used to need because if we didn't go
open we would have just gone into serial
monogamy you know because she needed the
validation of different people loving
her I needed the validation of different
people sleeping with me you know so we
would we split up and we would have
continued to just go a year two years
you know however long with a person
until we sucked up all the validation
that we could get from that person then
we would have moved on and then sucked
it up from somebody else then moved on
but now I think both of us can be like
wow that was really [ __ ] hard but I
actually feel whole I feel like I don't
need anything anymore I feel like I
learned I learned my own pathology and
healed my own pathology to the point
where I'm good do you think that you
could still adopt this mentality of sort
of disconnecting from the validation and
not needing it with one person totally
do you think that's a good idea yeah I
think I'd be a sign up for that one well
I think we're in a whole I think feeling
whole no matter what yeah and then
celebrating you know celebrating whoever
you're with happiness yeah you know
genuinely without needing anything from
them so if the person you know I'm
dating somebody now and like you know
we're just dating but you know in the
dating process there's gonna be other
people that you see and usually in
dating protocol when you're just
starting off dating somebody you really
just don't talk about it and and I was
taught of like look I'm happy for you to
tell me whoever you're seeing like oh
I'll celebrate it with you was it good
you have a good night
like what do you mean this is crazy I
don't trust this I was like no for real
and then she's like getting more used to
she's like yeah you know I had a saw
this guy than that was like how was it
just like it was great I was like that's
awesome
she's like this is a trick I was like no
it's not a trick like I'm genuinely
happy for you you know like I'm just
happy that you're having a great time
and and I'd like it's really interesting
because that's not the old me the old me
would have been [ __ ] up really [ __ ]
on the streets of New York you're
holding around been like why does she do
it I wonder if he's better than me I
wonder if she's gonna love him more than
I'm wondering oh my god and I'd be all
freaked out and then we ruined my day
and now you know happen knowing that I'm
whole and that I'm okay and that if that
person is actually better for her you
know that would be a bummer but okay
that's fine like allow that truth to
exist you know and if that truth is what
exists that's okay cuz I'm I'm whole
it's not gonna hurt me if she makes that
choice I don't be bummed out but if
that's the right and best choice that's
the right and best choice don't you
think it finds its way anyway though
like if you aren't right for each other
it's gonna find its way anyway Oh
without having to complicate things with
pain which I I mean yeah pain is a topic
I want to talk about but don't you think
you can just go through the transition
yourself something together with one
person and yeah sure some people some
people can become whole this is one way
to become home right this is not like
the way for everybody I'm not like
saying deep dive into becoming this is a
deep dive and for people who are
particularly screwed up you know in this
nest who really have a deep need for
validation from the opposite sex which I
did like I don't think there was another
way I did I did all the ayahuasca I did
all the plant medicine I did all the
other things I was trying I was trying
all kinds of stuff but nothing like
brought me to my knees to the point
where I really had to deal with my need
for particularly a female to love me in
an intimate way for me to be able to
love myself that was the necessity for
me to be able to love myself
well this allowed me to cure that
pathology and
and and in for Whitney it allowed her to
cure that for herself as well in her own
way in her own way for needing it wasn't
so much about the sex but it was about
the attention affection desire being
desired by multiple people you know I
think both of us can say yeah we made a
ton of mistakes some parts were amazing
and some parts were truly amazing like
true like I'm talking about the negative
parts there was amazing parts we had
amazing times together and so much love
shared not only with each other but with
other people as well but you know really
it's a path of growth and what we do in
the future you know what we do in the
future is is undetermined but I think
you know really looking at this maybe
it's a long-term solution for some
people maybe it's just a path of growth
mm-hmm I certainly wouldn't do it the
same way that that we did it we learned
a lot we went way too far in some ways
you know and I think we made a lot of
mistakes yeah but that's the learning
process
[Music]